but so this is the tar
you hear that do you hear that
and sometimes just dirt
that's what you should hear
not
oh
not that
so the
this is really good all right
so it could be a lot worse but if you go
there so when you've got the taranuchi
so if you put yuck in it when you've got
the tarunucci
you should look at your cane and as you
cut it down because it's rubber
it might jump to the left
it might jump to the right so these are
all things that if you've got a
tavernuchi or you try at any stage these
are things you'll see or you'll get
you'll get this
the thing to do is
you since you said you squeeze it like
like ringing water out of a towel at the
very end so you go squeeze
you then have a little injection going
forward
all right so you don't just
cut it down
but you squeeze you feel the difference
in the all right so if you just go down
is that if you go forward
is that
has more power in going forward because
it becomes like a slice all right so
mustn't go to the left it mustn't go to
the right
it mustn't bounce
I used to have a a young student 19
years of age I used to hit the tar and
keep in it and you could see the tar
sort of bead most people that hit the
target sort of like took them back
so that what you then take from it is
you now use the Bounce from the tire
and this is really what we've been
talking about this morning in Aikido we
use like I was timing with the partner
when I hit that
I'm going to use the energy to get the
can up there
if I go like that and now mechanically
do this this is what I call Basic School
you feel the difference in the power
so you have to work out
are you out of breath you know did you
put everything into the car
or ah
or can you use the power that the first
one gave you so the taranuchi is not
just the tar that you whack away
thinking it's going to make your hips
strong
and then somebody asked me about in the
31 Carter five six seven eight
if I take this energy
then you can do in the 31 Carter
without going like this
five six seven
eight
you know one's mechanical physical the
other one is energized
and then you you start learning happy
different directions
because you know I was talking about
sensing spiritual and that you're in a
dimension where time isn't
thought of or time
is my kind of isn't available
all right so you do the footwork
and then you just do it and of course I
ain't got time at all have I haven't got
time to think so so but I'm
I'm working on oh the bounce I'm working
on the oh oh oh
so I'm having to demonstrate by
pretending the bounce is there so I'm
putting the bounce in but really the
bounce is uh
created by the tamanucci all right so I
hope I've given you a bit of an Insight
in that
sorry
hey
when you do that if you're too focused
on just the cut
hey
you'll be stuck here
if you're think of the tavernuchi
you can keep flowing
okay thank you